okay here's a story that I love it's
part of our morning rounds new evidence
suggests that even a small amount of
exercise could lower the risk of
depression a recent study in JAMA
psychiatry looked at more than 600
thousand adults it assessed their
genetic makeup medical history and
physical activity levels and researchers
determined participants who were
genetically more likely to exercise may
be less likely to develop depression in
2016 an estimated 16 point 2 million
adults in the US had at least one major
depressive episode our dr. David agus is
here with the science behind exercising
for mental and physical health so this
is so fascinating because I think we
understand it intuitively to be true
that exercise makes you feel better but
this is the first study right to show
that physical activity could help
prevent depression what did we learn
this is important you know previous
studies have show during association
people who exercise have less depression
but this study in a very clever genetic
way where they actually able to use
genetics to randomize people because I
can't do a placebo control trial and say
you sit for five years and you exercise
but it's show causality right that
exercise itself no matter who you are
can reduce the risk of depression and I
thought one of them the most uplifting
things is that just 15 minutes of
jogging can do the trick right 15
minutes of jogging an hour of gardening
get outside and do something or if the
weather is like it is today in New York
do it indoors but the key is do
something every day you'll prevent the
risk of depression my patients now when
they come in and they say I'm starting
to feel a little depressed and not do as
much my first thing is not prescribe a
pill but get outside and do something
but when you're depressed David you
probably don't feel like exercising
that's that's that's what I find
difficult about this study no question
about Nevada I don't want to get up an
exercise so the first is to prevent
depression exercise so before you get
there
the second is yes you're right when
you're depressed nobody wants to go in
exercise the last thing you want to do
rise above that it's going to change how
doctors treat depression I hope so I
mean I certainly hope so we don't want
to reflux now right a pill let's really
push and try to prevent it everybody
when they come in say I need you to
exercise for your heart health for your
mind health and for your psychiatric
Kel's they're critical people are gonna
want to know what does this mean
exercise what is what how much does your
I trade have to go up and so forth and
what kind yeah yeah good so this study
showed that 15 minutes of jogging 2
hours a week 15 minutes a day can have a
benefit the way my rule of thumb to
patients is I love you every day to get
your heart rate 50% higher from where it
starts for 15 minutes if your heart rate
starts at 60 get it to 90 that's not a
crazy amount of exercise it means you
don't even need this I would be sweating
or out of breath just move is critical
so there had been a question about is
there a best time of day to exercise and
those who like to exercise at night some
might say you know you're not to be able
to go to sleep at night because you've
got all that endorphin rush this debunks
that correct well very coincidentally be
on it yesterday came out of studies
showing that if you exercise at night it
does not negatively affect sleep and I
think that's critical yeah right is that
you have to do what's best for your
schedule you have little kids you got to
get ready for school in the morning you
can't exercise now it says you can
exercise at night and it won't
negatively affect your sleep and it may
actually suppress what you eat which is
maybe in the end good for you also this
is the motto 2019 every darn day and she
said let's read every darn day darn I
have not done it every darn day but this
is very encouraging news I love to have
a positive story yes that's always good
to see you